these teams look a little bit tired
don't they mark but they're getting good
looks okay you just have to trust your
game i like the way they're running
their sets and getting
quality looks forget tired mitchell ties
the game at 74.
murray he pulls up and banks it home
murray got into go bear's chest and made
the shot
jamal murray coming alive with
consecutive buckets sneak layup over the
contested hand of gobert
[Applause]
nice bounce pass to o'neal and he
finishes at the rim
shot clock at five connolly in the paint
gobert finishing and we're tied
another play by mike kylian rudy gobert
feels like he got hit in the face and
certainly did it could have been easily
a
n-one plumlee trying to contest a dunk
attempt
swats him in the face jokic against
gobert
backs him down colbert stays on his feet
tough shot made it jokic giving denver a
two-point
lead 10 on the shot clock
had it back tapped he lost it the
nuggets come up with the defensive play
murray they missed the layup gobert got
it
mitchell hanging at the other end two
seconds to go
for the win and it rims out
denver hangs on
final score
etched across the face of mitchell
and the respect from two guys that will
be tied together for a long time
round two
[Applause]